it's my viewpoint that if a business
cannot pay
a hundred dollars or 200 to get someone
in the door
they don't have a marketing problem they
have a business problem
[Music]
i wanted to talk to you about a uh a
cash flow process
uh that i've i've been consistently
walking through for the last couple
months
part of this started with the book that
i'm still currently working on
called building a better mousetrap um
and all of that is around how you can
increase how much money you make per
customer that comes into your business
and so the easiest way to know if you
have an issue um is thinking about this
single question so i'm dealing with
a lot of agencies on our software side
and what i'm essentially walking them
through
is a cash flow quadrant but not the same
cash flow project that you'd have in
like
robert kiyosaki's rich dad poor dad but
a cash flow quadrant for how you can
increase the value per customer
because fundamentally um it's my
viewpoint that if a business cannot pay
a hundred dollars or two hundred dollars
to get someone in the door
they don't have a marketing problem they
have a business problem right they have
a cash flow issue
and they don't know how to acquire
customers and make cash flow up front
and so what i'll do is i want to walk
you through the four-step process
that i look at when i'm looking at a
customer that's coming in the door and
that doesn't matter what they're coming
in on they could come in on a
a free offer they could come in on a
lowberry offer like a
a new client special or something like
that that's a 29 i think 21 doesn't
really matter
or it could be a straight up value offer
where there's no discount whatsoever
there's no no free no nothing um simply
value being provided so those are
fundamentally the three types of offers
that exist in the marketplace free
discount and value
right but all of them can still lead to
the same mousetrap right
and so the first thing that i'll look at
is
products right is there something that
we can add on
in this sales choreography when someone
comes in the door so we can immediately
add a product purchase to
bolt-on to additional to an initial
service package right
so initial service package could be x
period of time x number of sessions
uh or a single session done at a
discount or even a single session free
like an evaluation or
or whatever right the point is is and
this works in any industry right you
could come in and obviously in the gym
and fitness space
the next natural cell for products would
be supplements right uh if you were in a
a chiropractor's
clinic the next natural cell might be uh
orthotics or a special pillow
or some sort of brace or whatever right
it's a physical product someone can
immediately purchase from you at a very
high margin
specifically to go with the service that
you're also selling them
another example might be if you're in
the beauty space you might sell
masks or serums or creams all of those
things would be
the first quadrant of how you can
increase how much you make per customer
right
so let's say i'm gonna use a hundred
dollars at the average like if you can't
pay a hundred dollars
for every person who walks in the door
in your marketing then you're not gonna
have a business
right you can't make if you can't make a
hundred dollars on a customer's coming
in in a service-based business you're
not going to succeed and has nothing to
do with your market it's because you
don't have
this process down so even if they come
in for free boom you sell 100 200
per person in product all right you've
already broken even on that but if you
still
want to really beat and dominate
everyone in the market you go to the
second quadrant
which is how can i get them to add on
additional services right
so this might be introducing them to
uh upsells within your core offer so if
you were a facility the gym facility for
example
you might have your large group training
but you might also have accountability
nutrition coaching semi-private training
all of those things would be add-ons to
the initial core offer
all of this will increase the average
lifetime value and investment of the new
customer that's coming in
which allows you to make more money all
right that's in a gym space if you were
looking at
a med spa someone comes in for a botox
you know treatment or whatever uh first
thing you're going to do is try and get
them to buy a package that's more of the
same thing but then also
give them what i would consider a menu
close which is uh let me show you
what other things we have to offer we
have coolsculpting we have filler we
have
microdermabrasion we have skin
tightening we have whatever right
all of those things would be showing
them what other
services and offerings you have for that
exact customer so that they can
so that they can become more valuable
you and that you can become more
valuable to them right
so cash flow quadrant number one is
product cash flow quadrant number two
is add-on services number three is
more from a uh for somebody who's more
capital constrained and wants to make
more money per customer up front
you can add on prepaid or financing and
so if you can if you're in a really
established industry you can get
financing companies to do this for you
care credit
is massive in the healthcare industry
people get you know get boob jobs
financed they get anything financed
through
care credit right if you can establish
that in your business you can get
uh sometimes half or more to finance
the packages that they may have
purchased from you so
the third piece there is just simply
asking and offering a 10
discount to get someone to pre-pay and
there's a key
note there you don't say paid in full
you some offer someone to prepay that's
the language around that
to drag some of that revenue up front or
certain cash up front
so that you can further liquidate the
cost of acquisition now let me
let me show you how powerful this is
with a single math example
if you have 10 people who walk in your
door and let's say you sell
five of them all right and one of those
five does a prepay
on your service right and let's say
everybody else averaged out to 500
um for the for the initial purchase but
one of them
paid twenty five hundred dollars right
that one twenty five hundred dollar sale
increases the average ticket from five
hundred to a thousand
across all of the customers that you had
in the door so even if a small
percentage take that offer
it can be a massive increase in the
average order value average cart value
average cash per show whatever way you
want to call it
um and can change the game in terms of
how you can acquire customers and beat
out
the people in your competitive space all
right so i went for
i've said three so far so product is
number one add-on services number two
getting people to pre-pay for services
that are happening in the future number
three
and then number four is continuity so is
there a way that we can also tie
continuity into this acquisition process
right so
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna not do the gyms
uh because everything i do is about gems
so i'm gonna try and
uh apply this in a different setting so
uh let's say we have uh i mean a med spa
is an easy one to use because i just
brought it up so someone comes in for a
discount botox
right first thing there they might not
make the surgeon or the med spa center
might not make a lot of money in that
first transaction they might make a
couple hundred dollars
but that should at least cover the cost
per show the next thing they're gonna do
is give them uh products right the
products that are gonna go
with that might be uh the serums the
macs at home
because everything that someone's coming
in for there wants to look younger and
more beautiful right
and so all all the products that would
go along with that
uh would immediately be sold from like a
take-home kit standpoint like if you
want to maintain these results or extend
these results you should have these
things
the next would be our menu clothes right
do you want to do microdermabrasion you
want to do the coolsculpting do you want
to do filler whatever
right then we're going to prescribe
a package that's going to be their total
beauty package um
which might take six months or whatever
to get them to where we where they want
to be
and then the continuity that we're going
to tie into this is a process that i
like to call
down selling the upsell all right and so
what that is is
typically you'll want to have people pay
more in the beginning because it costs
more to acquire a customer it costs more
to onboard a customer that does to
maintain a customer
and so if we're getting more cash up
front for these customers they're going
to be more invested in our process
and it also allows us to cover the
overhead of getting them activated
getting them on board and giving them a
great experience
but then you can simply offer them the
same thing that they've been getting
but just on a recurring basis and do it
at a pretty decent discount and most
people will jump at that offer
what it does is then locks that person
into regular recurring cash flow for the
business
and then massively extends the lifetime
value of the customer
and so i'm going to walk you through one
single math example then i'll sign off
but hopefully you can look at that
quadrant within your existing
sales process and say how can i
implement each of these four things
into the sales choreography in my
business so that i can outspend my
competition
so that um i can spend five hundred
dollars per person who walks in the door
a thousand dollars per person walks in
the door
and the reason that's so important is
because if you can get that cash per
show
high enough then you can spend on
multiple different channels
of acquisition you can have referral
partners you can have you can have cold
traffic you can have
affiliates you can have all of these
different venues you can have you can
have direct mail you can have
uh social media stuff you can like all
of these different venues cost different
amounts but at a certain point all of
them become affordable
and that is what unlocks the huge
amounts of growth that are available for
a business owner
and it comes from the back not the front
and so everyone thinks they have a
marketing problem but typically it's
because they have
a monetization issue they're not good at
cash flowing or choreographing
the the money that they're making per
customer right
so to to bring this all home
what we're trying to figure out is how
much can we make up front in the first
30 days
and then what's the lifetime value of
the customer the cash value for the
first 30 to 60 days is going to be
important
for how you spend money to get them in
the door the lifetime value on the back
end is going to be how much money you're
going to be able to extrapolate
and how much revenue you make per month
based on your sales volume
so for example if you sell 20 people
every single month and you know
that your lifetime value per customer is
2 000
total and you sell 20 customers per
month total
then it means that your business should
cap out at 20 times 2 000
which should be 40 000 a month and
that's an easy way to back into like if
you feel like your business has not been
able to grow it's because one of t is
two numbers either you're not
you're not capturing enough on the back
end or you don't have a big enough
inflow that is
it that's all there is to it you can
massively simplify this
now if we're looking at trying to back
into that number
so let's take a business a that can only
pay a hundred dollars per show which
means they're not making a lot of money
and then option b is we've got a
business that could pay a thousand
dollars to show
let's see if we can reverse engineer a
thousand dollars per show
uh into a business model so if someone
comes in and let's make it an attractive
front-end offer let's make it a let's
make it a
a 19 new client special whatever
right evaluation it doesn't really
matter what industry it is it works the
same way
all right so someone comes in for a 19
thing they show up
all right from there let's say that we
know that we're going to close half
uh onto uh the next service package
right
now that next service package let's say
the average is going to be two thousand
dollars
all right now that's going to be over an
extended period of time cool
let's say that our minimum that we can
get down is 500 because that's what we
say is minimum in order to buy and
that's why we're closing half and not
100
right the next thing we do is we sell
200
per customer now if two thousand dollars
was what the package was we closed half
we're at a thousand dollars in lifetime
value all right just from that first
transaction
half times two thousand is a thousand
all right now of all those people that
say yes
now let's say we sell each of those
people two hundred dollars for the
product
all right now we added 200 so now we're
at 1200
lifetime value then let's say uh two
out of those five people that we you
know that we sold for example
um decide to add on an additional
thousand dollars for the services
all right from your other service
offerings that you have
all right so now we've got two fifths
times a thousand uh which would be
four hundred dollars uh that we add
again to the customer so now we're at
sixteen hundred dollars
per show all right and then again
on the back of that we say hey we know
that from every of the five that we have
um we can get uh let's say another two
to sign owns a continuity at two hundred
dollars a month and we turn out at ten
percent
which tax another two thousand dollars
onto two of those customers
all right and so that would add yet
another
eight hundred dollars on top so you'd be
at twenty four hundred dollars
per person that walked in the door for a
free offer
all right that is how you can beat
everyone in your marketplace is that you
consistently
execute the process right that means
every
single time you have a choreographed
handoff between service a
or service one and sale number two so
number two and cell number three so
number three and cell number four
and if part of you is like man i feel
like i'd be selling all the time
yes is the answer but but the secondary
correlate to that is that if you look at
the research that exists on how to
maintain a customer
over the long haul it's about expansion
revenue
it's about ascension it's about selling
them more
things over time so that they can
continue to be reminded of the value
that you provide because over time
people always want new things
and so it is your duty if you believe in
the value that you provide to make the
offers
to those people and communicate that
process in a seamless way
so that every part of your business
knows my objective
is passing the baton from point b to
point c from point c to point d
and all of that choreographed process
ultimately results
in a front end that allows you to spend
whatever you want per customer
uh because your backend is so strong and
that process
that cash flow quadrant is the reason
that jim launch has been able to stay
number one in this industry
despite the saturation despite the
charlatans despite
the many people who would claim that
they're doing the same thing
but they're not because they don't
execute that process and at the end of
the day
what you are always going to be paid for
is the value that you can create in the
marketplace
we've been able to choreograph that
process for the businesses that we serve
so that they make more per customer and
so that their customers are better
served
and that's ultimately what you have to
do what we have to do as entrepreneurs
and business owners is how can i serve
my customer in the highest and best
degree ever
and how can i do it in as seamless a way
as possible so that i can have as little
operational drag as possible
so that um i can outmarket my
competition and continue to play the
game
so anyways uh that cash flow uh
quadrant is is how i think through the
choreography
around uh creating selling systems
so that our gyms and our businesses can
beat out their competition and i would
encourage you to
print that out put it put it somewhere
so you can think about every single
sales process that you have through that
lens
and i guarantee you that you'll make
more money that's what
that's what when i do my consulting days
and i sell consulting hours
this is the process that i walk those
business owners through and
nine times out of ten um we can almost
double or triple the amount that they
make the customer simply following that
process
so i hope that was valuable for you i
hope you have an amazing saturday
execute that make more money serve at a
higher level and crush it
lots of love catch you soon